solidarité en action au foyer d'accueil
chartrain théâtre de la deuxième étape
de la partie cycle action une première
du genre en région
une balade à vélo pour commencer entre 5
et 10 km à travers la ville à chartres
arrêt obligatoire à la cathédrale pour
admirer souffler un peu premier souvenir
premières impressions j'ai toujours
connu la fumisterie et tout ça mais mais
là il ya une certaine cohésion c'est un
chaleur en tout la famille quoi voilà ça
représente quoi pour vous ça ben
l'amitié l'amitié la la convivialité la
sociabilité au moment des changes de
partage et de bonne humeur avec la
remise dès l'arrivée d'un mano à coiffer
maison pour anthony le meilleur grimpeur
de l'étape chercheurs d'emploi il a
trouvé refuge et soutien aux foyens ça
nous permet de ne poser et c'est au
niveau du mental quoi parce que je veux
je connais beaucoup de personnes qui
justement sont on n'en auront pas la
chance là et ont un mental que moi de se
défoncer trois dj allez quoi se défoncer
pour avancer et reprendre confiance
trente ans maintenant que l'association
chartraine agi pour et avec les
personnes en grande précarité sociale
par les actions de ce type
chacun son rôle chacun sur
responsabilités et ça marchait il y en a
ça fait deux trois ans que je les
connais c'est vrai que ça permet aussi
de voir l'évolution de chacun il y en a
compris des places énorme en tout cas
dans ses actions voilà ils étaient
accueillis maintenant ils sont plus
accueillis mais par contre ils restent
dans les actions en tant que vraiment
personne citoyenne etc d'où l'intérêt en
fait moi c'est ce que j'aime voir c'est
comment la personne arrive à retrouver
un rôle dans la société à travers ce
mode de participation fin de l'escale
eurélienne la partie cycle action
poursuit sa route du cher jusqu'au bout
reichert